ces hautes lumières soir ça a marché
bouteilles de lait fpsl pour cédric le
fromage et saucisses escalopes de boeuf
et salades macédoine pour jean-philippe
le boucher charcutier
ils constatent que leur initiative
répond à un vrai besoin du consommateur
qu'il veut pouvoir faire ses courses en
semaine après 19 heures ou le week end
selon ses disponibilités à gauche
produits laitiers fait défiler on n'est
pas toujours disponible aux heures
d'ouverture des magasins donc on est
libre de venir quand on veut on trouve
nos produits frais ce qui est plutôt
agréable co2 plus de surcroît c'est des
produits locaux
voilà donc je suis ravi de
l'installation des deux de ses
distributeurs
à côté se trouve le distributeur de pain
et viennoiseries les commerces se trouve
à 100 m pour le boucher en centre ville
pour le boulanger et a cure bini à deux
kilomètres de là pour le fromage et une
union de trois commerçants et artisans
locaux qui fait la force de ce projet
l'avantagé dès que justement dès la 24
sur 24 7 sur 7 ce qui nous permet un
petit peu de contourner la loi qui nous
oblige de fermer une journée par semaine
installé en périphérie de la commune ce
distributeur fait aussi des heureux dans
le centre-ville à 800 mètres de là le
dimanche matin 11h30 on fait envers le
clou c'est tout fermé on va là-bas pour
ton cas de le louper d'ordre charme
nature oui c'est possible que j'achète
j'achète la poigne réfrigéré à 4 degrés
ce distributeur offre les mêmes
garanties qu'un achat classique en
boutique
les commerçants se donne quelques mois
pour voir si leur projet séduit